what's up everybody
if you are not familiar with the picture
called the last swarm ah here it is this
was created by digital artist vos logic
you can check them out on Twitter and
Instagram just search boss logic and
also put the links down in the
description below also a reminder about
the infinity war blu-ray giveaway I'm
doing all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero so the last
warm-up was really popular before
Avengers infinity war came out obviously
playing off the photo of the Last Supper
this image showed all of our heroes at a
table essentially implying that they're
all gonna die and we were half right
because half of them did die but half of
them survived so boss logic went and
created a last war matoom it's
essentially the first one he created
with only the avengers who survived the
snap and if you compare the first image
to the second it's actually really sad
to see all of the heroes that aren't
with us anymore
so obviously this new photo shows only
the remaining Avengers but there are a
few things to note here that are
actually pretty cool slash pretty sad if
you look all the way to the left you can
see Clint Barton aka Hawkeye with a card
in his hand that says save one thing
that is uncertain but highly speculated
is that Hawkeye's family will actually
die because of the snap and that causes
Hawkeye to turn into Ronin next is Tony
Stark it looks like he is holding
spider-man's
original Spidey mask obviously you can
see him mourning here he clearly has
great sorrow and guilt that Peter Parker
died
you can catch Stanley there in the
background it seems like he's consoling
Thor and to Thor's left is Captain
Marvel and she seems to have in her hand
the same paging device that Nick Fury
had in the mid credit scene of Avengers
infinity war perhaps the saddest one
here is Rocket holding groots old video
game one of the saddest things that I
heard about Avengers infinity war came
from the Russo brothers themselves when
they said that groots final words I am
Groot to Rocket were dad so you
essentially have a father here holding a
big
game of his son who was no longer with
him so just wanted to show you all this
I think it's an amazing job done by boss
logic make sure you all check them out
it definitely hits you with the
devastation of thanasis snap so let's
hope that somehow our heroes return in
Avengers 4 be sure to subscribe like and
comment below with your favorite
superhero to enter the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway thank you all so much
for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]